I WOULDN'T VOTE FOR ME.
HERE WITH REACTION THE
AUTHOR OF THE BEST SELLING
BOOK "VENGEANCE" FORMER
SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE NEWT
GINGRICH.
YOU ARE LAUGHING.
I'M LAUGHING, TOO.
I FORGOT THE GOOD OLD DAYS.
THERE IS SOME TRUTH IN WHAT
HE IS SAYING IN THIS REGARD.
I THINK WE HAVE A SERIES OF
SCANDALS AND LOOKING AT
DEVON NUNES TODAY THAT THE
ABUSE OF GOVERNMENT
SURVEILLANCE BY THE FBI IS
SO BAD AND ALL THAT WE ARE
UNCOVERING HERE IS SO BAD,
HE'S RIGHT, THE MAINSTREAM
MEDIA, YOU KNOW, THEY WANT
TO DESTROY TRUMP AND THEY
LOVED HIM.
IT'S THAT SIMPLE.
>> LOOK, AND AND I HAVE
KNOWN EACH OTHER A LONG
TIME.
SO I'M GOING TO SPEND SOME
OF YOUR MONEY.
WHY DON'T YOU OFFER $100,000
TO CREATE THE BARACK OBAMA,
ON THE SHOW WITH YOU.
THAT'S SUCH A FUNNY SEGMENT.
>> Sean: DONE.
>> I'M JUST TELLING YOU.
I LISTENED TO IT AND I
THOUGHT TO MYSELF, THIS GUY
IS SO WHACKED AND TODAY I
MEAN, HE STILL DOESN'T GET
IT.
HE WILL NEVER GET IT.
MANY, MANY YEARS FROM NOW,
IN A NURSING HOME OR A NICE
RETIREMENT COMMUNITY, BARACK
OBAMA WILL BE STILL LIVING
IN A FANTASY LIFE.
HE WILL THINK THAT IRAN
SHOULD REALLY WANTED TO HAVE
A DEAL.
HE WILL THINK THAT HIGH
TAXES REALLY WORK.
FUNNY A STATEMENT OF WHO
BARACK OBAMA IS AS I HAVE
EVER SEEN.
IT CAPTURES THIS SENSE OF
BEING OUT OF TOUCH WITH
REALITY.
>> Sean: LET'S TALK ABOUT
THE MEDIA IN THIS SENSE.
THEY SPENT A YEAR,
MR. SPEAKER.
THERE'S NO EVIDENCE OF
TRUMP-RUSSIA COLLUSION.
WE PLAYED THE MONTAGE OF
DEMOCRATS SAYING THERE IS NO
EVIDENCE OF COLLUSION.
YET, WE DO HAVE EVIDENCE OF
UNBELIEVABLE INSTANCE OF
UNMASKING, AND LEAKING RAW
INTELLIGENCE.
WE KNOW THAT THE FIX WAS IN
WITH HILLARY AND BERNIE.
THEY HAD AN EXONERATION
BEFORE EVEN AN
INVESTIGATION.
WE KNOW THAT HILLARY PAID
FOR A DOSSIER FULL OF
RUSSIAN PROPAGANDA.
WE KNOW THAT DOSSIER NOW WAS
USED TO GET FISA WARRANTS TO
SPY ON OPPOSITION CANDIDATE
AND A PRESIDENT-ELECT AND
HIS TEAM.
AND I'M NOT EVEN TALKING
ABOUT URANIUM ONE OR DEBBIE
WASSERMAN SCHULTZ.
THERE SEEMS TO BE -- THERE
ARE TWO REALITIES HERE.
AND THE MEDIA HAS CHOSEN A
REALITY OF PARTISANSHIP AND
CONSPIRACY THEORIES.
COULD WIN AND PEOPLE LIKE
YOU AND ME WERE RIGHT.
>> LOOK, WHAT YOU HAVE TO
UNDERSTAND AND I'M ACTUALLY
WORKING ON A BOOK CALLED
TRUMP'S AMERICA, TRYING TO
UNBELIEVABLY HARD TO
UNDERSTAND IF YOU'RE A
NORMAL PERSON.
OVER HERE IS A LEFT WING
CORRUPT ESTABLISHMENT, WHICH
SINCERELY SEES THIS ENTIRE
FIGHT AS A FUNCTION OF
IDENTITY POLITICS IN WHICH
IF THEY LOSE, THEY WILL
DISAPPEAR.
OVER HERE ARE THE REST OF US
WHO ARE THINKING, YOU KNOW,
A LOT OF THESE IDEAS ARE
REALLY WEIRD, I MEAN, OBAMA
THOUGHT IF YOU GAVE
$100 BILLION TO IRAN, THEY
WOULD BE NICE PEOPLE.
OBAMA THOUGHT IT WAS
TERRIFIC THAT WE HAD MORE
PEOPLE ON FOOD STAMPS THAN
EVER BEFORE.
YOU HAVE A WHOLE LIST OF
THESE THINGS.
AND THIS IS REALLY A
AND SO WHAT YOU AND ARE
LIVING THROUGH IS A PERIOD
WHERE THE OLD ORDER, THE
ESTABLISHMENT THAT INHERITED
AND THIS IS IMPORTANT TO
UNDERSTAND.
THEY INHERITED WALTER
CRONKITE.
THEY INHERITED EDWARD R.
MURROW.
THEY INHERITED THE OLD
HARVARD.
THEY INHERITED ALL THESE
GREAT CENTERS OF AUTHORITY
AND RESPONSIBILITY AND THEY
HAVE GRADUALLY TURNED THEM
INTO LEFT WING NUT CAKE
POSITIONS.
AND SO, THE TRUTH IS WE'RE
IF THEY WIN, WE DISAPPEAR.
THAT'S WHY WHAT YOU AND I
EXPERIENCE, BECAUSE WE ARE
GREAT FRIENDS, WE'RE GREAT
WARRIORS IN THE SAME CAUSE,
AND WE BOTH UNDERSTAND IF WE
LOSE, WE WILL LITERALLY
DISAPPEAR.
ON THE OTHER HAND, IF WE
WIN, AMERICA WILL CONTINUE
TO MOVE FORWARD AS THE
OF US FIGHT.
>> Sean: YOU ARE DESCRIBING
WHAT TRULY MOTIVATES US BUT
THAT'S A SEPARATE ISSUE.
AS A PRACTICAL MATTER, CAN I
HIS TRUE RECORD IS ON THE
ECONOMY.
YOU MENTIONED IRAN.
YOU THINK HE CAN BRIBE
MURDERING THUG DICTATORS AND
NOT MENTION RADICAL ISLAMIC
TERRORISM AND IN A YEAR OF
TRUMP, YOU CAN COMPARE
POLICY SIGNIFICANT CHANGES
WITH TANGIBLE RESULTS.
BUT THE MEDIA WON'T TALK
ABOUT ANY OF IT.
>> LOOK, YOU WOULD THINK IF
BARACK OBAMA WAS A SINCERE
PERSON WHO GENUINELY CARED
ABOUT AFRICAN-AMERICANS,
WHEN YOU GOT A REPORT THIS
WEEK THAT WE HAVE THE LOWEST
BLACK UNEMPLOYMENT IN YEARS,
BECAUSE THE ECONOMY IS
STARTING TO WORK.
TRUMP'S TAX CUTS, REGULATORY
CUTS, PRO-BUSINESS ATTITUDE
IS STARTING TO WORK.
YOU WOULD THINK THAT HAVING
THE LOWEST BLACK -- LOWER
THAN ANY TIME UNDER BARACK
AFFORD TO BELIEVE IT NANCY
PELOSI CAN'T AFFORD TO
BELIEVE IT CHUCK SCHUMER
CAN'T AFFORD TO BELIEVE IT
BECAUSE IF IT WAS TRUE, THEY
WOULD DISAPPEAR.